I think there's been a shattering of a
lot of myths and Illusions and delusions
this week what did Israel get in return
and gave the land but the peace never
came this is what has come I think that
this week has the potential to finally
and forever separate out liberals from
anti-liberal they were celebrating
Jewish Slaughter and people should never
ever forget that if you don't believe in
Good and Evil after this week
you're
sleepwalking Barry it's been a pretty
insane week what have we
learned I think we've learned I think
there's been a shattering of a lot of
myths and Illusions and delusions this
week we can start maybe in the Middle
East and then move on to the ideology
that has captured so many of our Elite
institutions that has revealed itself uh
for the moral perversion sort of lies at
the heart of it but if we go to Israel
um and begin on the early hours of
Saturday morning when Hamas terrorists
infiltrated the Border via air and land
and sea coming with one intention and
one intention only which is not the
liberation of the Palestinian people but
the annihilation of the Jewish people
and that is what they did in the ensuing
hours by now I hope anyone watching this
knows the horror that that ensued um but
just to give people a sense for those
who are reading things claiming that all
of this is sort of propaganda or
misinformation families whole families
were burned
alive babies were
beheaded women who had gone to an EDM
music festival in the desert
were raped next to the corpses of their
friends and as of this morning and we're
recording on Monday morning more than
199 people were taken hostage into Gaza
and God knows what is happening to
them it's the kind of Massacre that if
you follow Jewish history you might
expect from a pogram in Eastern Europe
in the 19th century but here it was
taking place in the state formed after
the Holocaust that was meant to be a
safe even for the Jewish people so what
have we learned I think one thing we
have learned is that
Hamas told us who they were and yet
somehow we forgot somehow Israel in a
way forgot the Reckoning of of how this
happened and how the most militarily
sophisticated country in the world could
have been so caught off guard and could
have allowed itself to be the site of
the worst massacre single day massacre
of Jews since the Holocaust that is the
Reckoning that's going to take place
over the next weeks and months and years
but I think for sure one thing we know
is that Hamas fooled Israel and Hamas
fooled the world right Israel believed
and was giving these permits for people
in Gaza to come work over the Border
Hamas gave the perception that it was
war weary and and just wanted sort of to
to get along and of course that revealed
itself not to be true I think one of the
other things that a lot of us are
thinking in the wake of these past
horrendous days is the idea we all or
most of us grew up on right most of the
Jewish World grew up on the idea of a
two-state solution the idea that if we
could trade land away if Israel could
trade land away then we would get peace
in return but I think one of the
tragedies of the past week is all of us
wondering whether or not that's actually
true right Israel to remind people does
not occupy the Gaza Strip it pulled out
in 2005 it dismantled every single
Israeli Community there gave back
everything there has not been a single
Jew in Gaza until now in the form of 200
hostages being held there and yet what
did Israel get in return and gave the
land but the peace never came this is
what has come and so I think it's
leaving many people who feel like the
moral situation with Israel having to
occupy the West Bank otherwise known as
Judea and Samaria it's a horrible
situation and yet what would happen if
the thing we've all prayed for for our
entire lives happened which is at least
me as a liberal Jew Israel pulls out
well then is it just going to have
another Hamas terrorist statelet at its
other border so I think that is one of
the things that we're currently
reassessing um I think the other thing
that has been shattered in the wake of
this Massac
is the Folly of a of a foreign policy
embraced by the Obama Administration and
then revived by the Biden Administration
to I don't know what the right word is
but to do business with Iran right and
you could justify that policy maybe in
2014 2015
2016 I don't think that there is any way
to justify that policy today Iran are
the pay masters of Hamas we read in the
Wall Street Journal they literally gave
the orders for this attack so why is the
United States pursuing a policy Visa
Iran by which we're giving them billions
of dollars it doesn't make sense Barry
uh Sam Harris and Eric were here uh this
interview will go out before theirs but
one of the things people will hear Sam
talk about is essentially that we have
misunderstood the nature of the threat
which is Hamas uh is not about
liberating Palestine or anything like
that these are jihadis and they're
driven by that motivation is that your
take on this yeah and I would say that
you know when people mistakenly talk
people well-intentioned progressives who
don't know very much about the history
talk about Gaza being occupied and
they're inadvertently right Gaza is
occupied by a terrorist group called
Hamas which uses the most barbaric
weapons of war Mass rape of women the
killing of the elderly the disabled and
children but more than that it is using
a weapon of of the sacrifice of its own
citizens right it there are there are
rules in war There are rules in war and
Hamas literally sets up its operations
in hospitals in schools so that they can
actively try to create as many civilian
deaths as possible that is their actual
aim Israel is begging Gins that live in
half of the strip to go to the other
half in order to save civilian lives
because that is what an ethical military
does there's always going to be horrific
tragedy in war but instead Hamas is
countering and saying stay in place and
that is part of their strategy why
because they want civilian deaths in
order to create rage around the world
against Israel and so it
is
it is
unspeakable what they are doing to the
people of Gaza and if anyone has any
Illusions about what Hamas is just look
at what they did look at what they did
and look now as the ground operation
against Gaza is beginning at what
they're doing to their own
people Benjamin Netanyahu has
is how can I put this they there's a lot
of people who are quite rightly furious
with him because they be he they believe
that he's let the Israeli people down
the IDF were found wanting can you
explain a little bit of what actually
happened in terms of security how did
this awful tragedy occur we don't know
the answer to that yet um here's what we
do know Israel for anyone who's been
paying attention over the past year has
been in the most heated almost cold
Civil War among its population about
whether or not these so-called judicial
reforms that some people view as overdue
and that other people view as bringing
Israel to the brink of a constitutional
crisis even though it doesn't have a
constitution but the brink of sort of
the end and the unraveling of democracy
there have been massive protests in the
streets and by the way it's not just
secular liberal versus the hardcore and
Orthodox many of my Orthodox friends in
Israel have been taking to the streets
every single weekend with their family
to protest the Netanyahu so-called
judicial reform we don't have time to
get into what that reform looks like but
the the takeaway is that Israel was
internally weakened Israel was
internally weakened you had people who
were who were um high-ranking officers
in the Israeli Defense Forces saying
that because of what Netanyahu was doing
because of the judicial reform and
because of the bigots that he had
brought into his coalition government
they wouldn't be showing up if they were
called to duty so that is the sort of
State of Affairs internal to Israel when
when Hamas terrorists start cross over
the border on Saturday the other thing
that was happening was that it was um a
major Festival holiday and my
understanding is that a lot of troops
that would typically have been at the
border with Gaza had been moved to the
West Bank but you know again we don't
know the full extent you have to think
for a second this is the this is the
most militarily sophisticated country in
the Middle East they know if a bird
lands on the fence between Gaza and
Israel so how is it that more than a
thousand terrorists could simply cross
over the Border there's been reports
still unverified about a possible Cyber
attack that would have allowed for that
it's unclear as yet but I think if we
can take one takeaway a week in it's
that having a weakened internal society
that was divided against itself sent a
very very dangerous signal to Israel's
enemies and
obviously the events that occurred were
horrendous and awful how do you see the
respon to that how have you interpreted
the way that people have responded All
Around the
World perhaps it shouldn't surprise
those of us who have been
following the illiberal ideology that
has taken root among so-called
progressives and in our most elite
institutions among our institutions of
higher
education in all of our sensemaking
institutions in American life and yet
still I will never forget the shattering
that I feel watching college students
across America and across the world
cheering on the slaughter of Israelis
and not just Jews people from Thailand
people from all over Europe Americans
innocent people when people are Marching
on this on the quads of American
universities Singing Glory to the
martyrs when 50,000 people are Marching
on the Streets of London with images
printed out images of a Hamas paraglider
taped to their
shirt imagine on the days after
September 11th if 50,000 People March
through the Streets of London with an
image of the
al-Qaeda hijacked planes flying into the
World Trade Center or an image of aitz
or an image of Timothy McVey like these
are are symbols of Mass Slaughter mhm
and they are being it is being
celebrated it is being
celebrated we are seeing people Mass
around the Sydney Opera house screaming
gas the Jews gas the
Jews
and I guess if there's any Silver Lining
that has come out of this most horrific
week the most horrific week I think of
of my lifetime and I think the lifetime
of please God that will be the most
horrific week of of our lifetimes it is
that people have showed us who they are
people have showed us who they are and
they were serious when they said that
they were for decolonization they're
saying this is what decolonization looks
like decolonization wasn't an academic
idea decolonization is about the
massacre of
Jews and the massacre of Israelis so the
combination of college administrations
that have had so much to say about roie
Wade about the war in Ukraine about the
murder of George Floyd all of a sudden
have discovered the virtue of
institutional neutrality when it comes
to the massacre of Jewish people and
then Pro free speech now as well which
is really exactly exactly glad they
discovered that and so the combination
of the Silence of people that have moral
outrage for all kinds of other causes
but none when it comes to the massacre
of Jews combined with young people who
whether because they are brainwashed or
watch a lot of propaganda or genuinely
feel it are celebrating like I I think
it's very important to me for people to
understand when people the day after
this massacre were out there cheering
for it saying from The River To The Sea
Palestine will be free the bodies of
these burned people weren't even in the
ground yet they could not even be
identified so there's not even an
illusion that they were protesting the
Israeli the inevitable Israeli response
to this war they were celebrating Jewish
Slaughter and people should never ever
forget that Barry uh one of the reasons
that I think we've all opposed this
ideology is that it it reduces all human
interaction to this very basic oppressor
oppressed Dynamic and essentially seems
to have no rules for what should happen
to the oppressor right uh this is what
decolonization looks like and I think
you're right I think what you said about
London by the way I don't think it was
50,000 people with those badges a few of
it was 50,000 people and a few people
wearing those
and there were and there were people
chanting awful things there too I
suppose the question I want to ask you
and our good friend Douglas Murray was
recently on a British show with Julia
Hartley Brewer talking about the idea of
proportionality because a lot of people
uh are in my opinion rightly concerned
about the fact that there are going to
be very heavy civilian casualties in
Gaza as a result of this um and of
course I'm sure you will say as I will
say that the people who are responsible
for that are
Hamas but what
how do we manage that there are clearly
lots of people in the west who I think
it's fair to say are not anti-semitic
who don't hate Jews who nonetheless do
not want to see millions of people
killed and displaced no one wants to
see no one wants to see any number of
people in Gaza killed or displaced no
one but
unfortunately Gaza is ruled by a group
that actively wants them to die for the
sake of a propaganda campaign against
Israel a propaganda campaign by the way
that has been unbelievably and
enormously effective and if you want
evidence of that just look at we were
what Francis had just asked me about
before the evidence of it is everywhere
there are Ru there are basic rules of
War though and just just imagine if we
were here in the US and a group of
people came over the border and went
house to house and slaughtered our
children and took our grandparents
hostage or killed them and streamed it
live on their Facebook pages for their
families to see raped American women
what would America do in response it it
would have to eliminate the threat it
simply cannot live with that existential
threat at its border and I think that is
how Israel is is is seeing the situation
right now there's
never the idea that innocent people and
innocent children and women in Gaza
living under Hamas rule are going to die
in this war is horrible and should make
any person of
conscience
heartbroken period full stop but it's
really important for people to remember
why they're in that situation and
they're in that situation because they
are ruled by a group that is a
Latter-Day
Isis Barry did this surprise you the
outpourings because maybe it's me being
negative maybe it's me because I have
fames from the Middle East Lebanese
Lebanese Coptic Christians in that I
know the anger and I know the resentment
and when we talk about hatred it's a
word that is overused but there is a lot
of hatred in that area and I've seen it
from family members myself to the point
that I do find it shocking he he treated
of Jews and Israel yeah to put it
bluntly yeah and it it it the response
hasn't surprised me in a way I I kind of
knew knew that this was going to be the
backlash
because that resentment and that Fury
has always been
there so am I surprised by the reaction
the midd east or the West
both I'm not surprised by the reaction
in the Middle East because of everything
that you just referenced um I am and and
in a way you know I've been writing
about the campus issue since I was 19
years old okay that is at the time I
would not have had the courage to use
the phrase
anti-semitic but it is ABS there are
professors at Columbia University where
I graduated from that are absolutely
anti-semitic and that publish pieces in
the days after the massacre celebrating
the resistance and so I saw the roots of
this ideology and what it would mean not
just for the Jewish people but for
civilization and the
west back in 2003 when I was a College
freshman so in a way I'm not surprised
um but I think the thing that has that
has shattered me is is just how
widespread it is how excused it is from
the people who claim to want to hold the
moral High Ground on every other
issue one of the things that has
happened this week I have heard a lot of
friends who are left leaning on the
left Express
shock of what they've seen from their
own side what have they been saying I
can't believe this this isn't crazy I
can't believe the people on my side I
how are they justifying this I can't
believe they s like I can't believe is a
phrase I've heard a lot from people uh
people me too who are like woke AF you
know too uh so the question I suppose I
I want to ask you is given that I feel
like a lot of people's eyes have been
open this week do you think this is the
week that wokeness
ended
I I'm an optimistic person despite this
past week and I remain extremely hopeful
that this week can be a watershed moment
in finally opening people's eyes to the
the absolute illiberalism of this
worldview you have to ask yourself what
kind of world you would let people see
the massacre that we have just witnessed
and justify it or explain it or remain
silent in the face of it it's an
ideology that says people that
oppressors and we can discuss whether or
not Israel are the oppressors in the
situation of the Middle East they
deserve it they had it coming to them
that this is what decolonization looks
like MH I'm not an expert on the
politics I of Israel and
Palestine but it is also deeply
unsurprising to me seeing what's
happening in
Palestine the
Instinct
here given the
complexity is to see things in terms of
this is horrific what's happened to
Israel but when you all
examined colonization and
decolonizing
what did you actually think that would
look
like
like for real it is so interesting
watching people comment on
this when you are violently
oppressed for that
long what do you think the uprising
against your oppressors looks like and I
say this as a white person living in
colonized Australia on Stolen
land like some of you all need a bit of
a reality check I
think cuz like what did you think was
going to
happen what did you think Breaking Free
of colonial oppressor chains looked
like if you find yourself justifying or
explaining or remaining silent in the
face of babies burned alive with their
mothers you need to look in the mirror
and ask yourself what you've gone along
with and I think there are a lot of good
well-intentioned
progressives who have gone along with
this ideology thinking oh it's just
about social justice it's just about
inclusion it's just about diversity it's
just about making amends for past wrongs
of America and the West I really believe
that now they could be waking up to the
reality of the the the
conclusion in the real world of what
that ideology believes one bright spot
that has given me hope in the past few
days is that the universities which have
been essentially the hot beds not just
the the intellect the not just the
intellectual centers of this worldview
but really the the indoctrination
factories of of it um people donors are
finally saying it's enough you have Mark
Rowan an enormous donor to the Wharton
School at University of Pennsylvania Ivy
League school really important School of
Business saying we were silent for too
long in the face of an ideology that we
thought was just a little crazy well it
turns out it's not just a little crazy
it actually it is an ideology that
justifies the massacre of people as it's
happening and he's saying I'm closing my
checkbook and his model of Courage other
people have followed suit you have John
Huntsman who just there's the Huntsman
building is built at University of
Pennsylvania announced not another Penny
you have people pulling their funds from
places like Harvard and and the like and
I think it's I think that that is an
necessary and overdue move what colleges
like are free to do whatever they want
they're free to teach whatever they want
professors have academic freedom they
can go and public on the electronic
inana as Joseph mad did all hail the
resistance or whatever it was that he
wrote but that doesn't mean that good
people should be funding those ideas and
I think that this week A lot of people
are finally saying enough and you
mentioned the oppressor oppressed
Dynamics I want to steal man I know it's
painful and I know it's not pleasant to
do but I want to try and steal man the
argument that is being made by these
people so we can break it down right and
I think it's important to do because
whether we like it or not there are a
lot of people who who believe the The
Narrative that is being posted so the
narrative is that Israel is an occupying
force that Gaza is an open air prison uh
that people in Gaza live terrible lives
which they do they do um that Israel and
Israeli soldiers regularly commit
atrocities that Israel has bulldozed
Palestinian houses and Olive and so on
and that the I think the quote is
violence is the language of the
oppressed and this is what resistance
looks like one man's terrorist and
another man's freedom fighter and in the
same way that you and I might say well
civilian casualties and Gaza as a result
of Israel's bombings a collateral damage
that is inevitable they might say well
how is Gaza supposed to fight back how
are the Palestinians supposed to fight
back um and in the words of
congresswoman Alexandra Kazo Cortez I'm
always on the side of of the oppressed
right what say you to this argument well
let's start with the first thing you
said which is that Israel is an
occupying Force Israel has not occupied
Gaza since 2005 Ariel Chiron gave back
the Gaza Strip pulled out the Israeli
Army pulled out every single Jew that
lived in Gaza in the hopes of so-called
land for peace people would argue sorry
to jump in bar that the existence of the
state of Israel is defa occupation of a
land that was never supposed to be taken
over by the Israeli State because it
didn't exist that's what people would
say right and what I would say to that
is those people need to read a little
bit of History the Jews are indigenous
to the land of Israel full stop it
doesn't mean that there aren't other
groups like Palestinians then Arabs um
who are who also have a claim of
indigeneity to the land of Israel but
the Jews are indigenous to the land of
Israel and I think one of the reasons
that people have such a hard time with
this is that it's it's sort of an
anomaly in history in which a group that
is native to an area can be expelled and
massacred and decimated over 2,000 years
and yet have a continuous presence in
that land and ultimately come to
reestablish a sovereign state there it's
very hard for people to wrap their minds
around it the reason that Jews are
called Jews is because we come from the
land of
Judea most countries don't have a birth
certificate but Israel does in the Bible
and whether or not you believe in the
Divinity of the Bible or not it was
written in the land of Israel you know
you have to go back and look at the
history remember the UN partition plan
in 1947 that was meant to separate that
was meant to create two states and then
just go forward at every single period
over the past 75 years in history you
have one group of people the Jewish
people who then became the people of
Israel the Israelis who accepted a
partition plan from the United Nations
who said yes we are willing to have a
two-state solution and live in peace
with our neighbors the Arabs rejected it
that is the story of the past 75 years
it's the story of Israelis saying we are
willing to give land for peace all we
want is a safe haven for the Jewish
people which history unfortunately has
proven in our blood that and this week
once again showed that you know imagine
if this week happened and there was no
Israeli Army to fight back that is the
story of the Jewish people since since
we since the Exodus from Egypt you know
can I ask a really dumb question as
someone who really doesn't know this
conflict or understand it very well at
all can they just not can't can they not
give Gaza Independence and let them go
what do you mean they have let them Gaza
is ruled by
Hamas but they need food and water and
electricity from Israel right to survive
well but why is that I mean one of the
things I think people don't when people
talk about Gaza as an open air prison
they forget also that Gaza has a border
with Egypt right Egypt right now is not
letting these poor people well they
built a wall into Egypt yeah right like
why is that why is that and why isn't
there moral outrage around the world
about that why why is it Barry the Arab
states have taken a lot of Palestinian
refugees in the past they don't take any
now uh one of the reasons I think is
that whenever they have done in the past
it's led to very bad things happening in
their own countries I think also part of
it is that it is tragically for the
Palestinian people if very very good
they are a very very good political pawn
and tool to ferment rage against Israel
and the Jewish people
and how do we also how do we separate
this because this is very important
there are people people who are let's
just call them Pro Palestine but that
doesn't mean they're anti-semitic at all
how do we separate that because there
are people obviously anti-semitic pramas
want to see the extermination of a whole
race of people those people
unfortunately exist and they've existed
for thousands of years and that's just
the truth of it but there are also
people who are pro Palestine who are not
anti-semitic of course and those are the
people you hear who are saying clearly
right now and I wish there were more of
them yeah Hamas is evil and what Hamas
did to Massacre Israelis is absolutely
unequivocally evil and the reason that
I'm speaking out against Hamas is
because I believe in the dignity and the
liberation of the Palestinian people you
cannot be for the liberation of
Palestinians and not be against Hamas
and I think that's a very very clear
moral line there are many people I know
who are pro-israel and pro Palestine
one of the reasons that so many people
who are pro-israel are also for a
Palestinian state is a because we
believe in the sovereignty and the right
of people to establish their own fate in
their land the same logic that allows
someone to believe in the establishment
of the state of Israel leads them to
believe in the establishment of a
Palestinian State and the other part of
it is that if you're pro-israel surely
you don't want Israel occupying another
people it will create a moral rot in
your Society if you have to do that but
Israel has found itself in an impossible
situation as Gaza as what's happened in
Gaza has just showed us you pull out you
get a Hamas stat lit at your border you
don't pull out as they Haven in the West
Bank and you occupy another people I
think one of the things a lot of people
are going to be looking for in the wake
of this week is some kind of Third Way
some kind of paradigm shift that can
break us out of this impossible moral
knot and it's also with the situation in
the West Bank and look Barry I'm not as
of with this obviously as you are please
correct me if I say things that are
factually incorrect but for as long as
I've been aware of of the situation
that's been going on in the Middle East
people have been saying what's happening
in the West Bank is intolerable you know
Israeli settlers encroaching more and
more on Palestinian lands is that still
the case now it is definitely still the
case that there are Israeli settlements
in the West Bank from the sort of
Jewish perspective I'll say or certainly
the religious Zionist perspective the
West Bank otherwise known as Judea and
Samaria is where most of the most of
Jewish history the Biblical history took
place there's a lot of extraordinarily
holy sites there a lot of places that
are significant but as a liberal Zionist
and not a religious Zionist I have
always believed that I don't care what
holy history has happened in a place if
it can bring peace and save Israeli
lives and save Palestinian lives and
bring peace to the region give it back
it doesn't
matter and so you would give back the
entire West Bank I've always believed in
giving back the West Bank if it would
bring peace unfortunately in the wake of
this
week that view of mine that I have held
for my entire adult life has been shaken
to its core how can I like what would
that look like for the security of
Israel to Simply give it all back what
happens if Hamas or another terrorist
group comes to power there I don't think
a lot of people realize and maybe it'd
be useful to show your listeners or your
viewers a map of the entire Middle East
the Israel is the size of New Jersey it
is a tiny little
sliver and you know it would be an
existential threat You could argue if
Israel were to give away the West Bank a
view that I have held for again my
entire adult life that I now find myself
reassessing and then and then what
happens if peace doesn't break out is it
certainly didn't in Gaza and a terrorist
group comes to power there then what and
Barry one of the questions I want to ask
you is about the impact of all of this
here and let just say Constantine of
course the Jewish world like you you
have to remember that the pull out from
Gaza was instituted by one of the most
hawkish prime minister in Israeli
history Ariel Chiron and yet the
majority of Israelis and the majority of
the Jewish World supported it because
that is how desperate they were for
peace and I think that one of the
shattering and the reckonings of this
week is what do you do when your
neighboring population does not actually
seek
peace like what H it's not that the
people don't but the leadership doesn't
what do you do I mean if you go they
elected yeah yes what does that mean
right what does it mean this is the
question we're all wrestling with when
we had Sam and Eric in here I brought
this point up many
times I mean I I well I mean obviously I
don't know what the solution is but I
don't think anybody does that's why it's
it's going on right that's why it's an
unresolved issue it seems to me like a
physical separation of some kind is the
only answer here but there is a physical
separation and Israelis called it a
security barrier and Palestinians and
their supporters called it an apartheid
wall right there is a physical
barrier but but Gaza relies on Israeli
electricity water supplies for the
people there to survive that's why it's
not it's not a workable solution isn't
it isn't that the real reason well I
think the real reason it's not a
workable solution is because a group
that has in its Charter the explicit
annihilation of the Jewish people as its
reason for being is is is ruling over
they fundamentally don't accept the
existence of Israel let's be honest
right of let's be honest I mean yeah
guys let's be radical truth here yeah
well no what I mean is all of this stuff
about how you know uh you need to make
peace you need to do this it's all
bollocks because if these people don't
accept the right of the state of Israel
to exist in any way how can you have
peace how can there ever be peace if
these people want to see Israel wiped
off the map quote unquote how how can
you have
peace how is how is that going to be
peace I don't get it I don't know right
I got to be honest with you like as of
this morning peace is the last thing on
my mind the first thing on my mind is
how can Hamas and the threat that it
poses be destroyed I agree no and and
it's the right reaction it's understand
Hamas Israel has to destroy Hamas
there's no question about that but ultim
timately if we're talking about civilian
lives and people living and surviving in
Israel and in Palestine at some point
peace is going to have to be made and I
just don't see what that looks like I
don't get it I don't I don't see what
the solution is I have to be honest
today I don't see what the solution is
either yeah that's fine and a lot of a
lot of the slogans that I've written and
and chanted for my life my entire life
about a two-state solution about the
ability for there to be peace about I
feel mugged by reality in this week and
to me it comes back to that word again
hatred in that I don't think that people
in the west understand the depths of
hatred in its truest form that exist in
that region I always remember talking to
these relatives of mine being shocked
and horrified with people who are very
very intelligent very well
educated successful careers and they
would come out with things that would
make my skin turn even whiter than it
already is M which is very is very why
let's be
honest so and when you have because the
problem with hatred is not only that
it's a very powerful emotion a very
toxic emotion it it means that you're
irrational and that you will do
irrational things because it's such a
cancerous emotion that takes over and
destroys everything so until you deal
with that hatred I don't think you ever
going to solve the problem if I'm being
honest well
it's I saw videos this week maybe there
was so many videos that came out of the
horror but I watched a video of just a
young Palestinian girl beautiful in Gaza
probably five or six years old talking
about how wonderful it is when Jews are
slaughtered what do you do when a
population is indoctrinated in that way
yeah what do you do I don't know yeah
and that's why Hamas is who they are and
why they're allowed to why they're
allowed to flourish because they feed on
hatred that's what they do that's what
these people do that's what all
extremists do they they they allow the
narrative to be propagated they push the
narrative and then they feed off the
narrative yeah and that's the real worry
and then you look around at the
surrounding countries whether it's
Lebanon where my family originate from
or Iran or and the they're led by a lot
of them Islamic fundamentalists who also
un ironically a rabid anti- seit as well
because the two go together I think it's
just really really hard for people like
us that live
in I know this word has been overused
but like true privilege in the west
Western privilege Western privilege to
understand hate yeah and to understand
that the the what's driving this is not
poverty
or or or anything else other than an
ideology that is based on EMB the
Embrace of evil yeah like we live in a
culture in which like in which the even
the idea of Good and Evil seems like so
old fashion like how could anyone
believe in good and if you don't believe
in Good and Evil after this week you're
sleepwalking Barry when we had Sam here
uh one of our audience members we do a
special section on locals where people
get to ask our guest questions he was
asked a question by an audience member
Trump fa uh Sam famously not a fan of
trump we could we could put it put it
lightly put it lightly all recall the
the viral moment from the last time he
was on somebody said would this have
happened if Donald Trump was in power
it's impossible to know um but I can say
this I think whether because he was
perceived as strong or simply perceived
as crazy um the Middle East was a
changed place under his
presidency I don't know if I hate Trump
quite as much as Sam definitely not a
fan of trump but if you just look
putting aside his borish and his his
character just the policies that
happened under the Trump Administration
like the Abraham Accords like the
scuttling of the Iran deal these were
really really positive things for the
region and I don't think that you know
people can love Joe Biden people can
hate Joe Biden I don't think there's any
question that Joe Biden is not perceived
as a man at the height of his powers and
at the height of his strength and
certainly this administration's
re-embracing of their Randal framework
first put forward by the Obama
Administration has made the Middle East
a much much more dangerous place can I
say something else Barry about this as
someone who's kind of a Westerner but
also not yes and it comes back to your
point about people not understanding
that good and evil do exist there's
something else of people in the west
fundamentally don't understand which is
power and that's what you're talking
about Donald Trump
was borish
obnoxious
unpredictable but he was seen in places
where power is the one thing the only
thing that matters as powerful and as
someone who might react very harshly to
being crossed and that is a superpower
in the world and one of the things the
reasons I've been so concerned about the
direction of travel with all the stuff
that you and I all of us have been
talking about for a long time is we have
become deeply uncomfortable with the
exercise of power in the west and that
why I asked you the question about Trump
because there's no question in my mind
that neither Ukraine or this would have
happened be if Trump was still in power
for all the concerns that you might have
about him and the concerns might be the
flip side of the fact that he was
willing to use power to do things
exactly but we have fundamentally lost
the willingness to be powerful and it
bothers me tremendously I saw a tweet
this week that I kind of laughed at and
bookmarked to go back to which just said
American Empire didn't go far enough and
it was sort of glib but I I really I've
been thinking about what what was the
groundwork that was laid that allowed
for this week and I think a big piece of
it is American weakness and America's
sort of recession from the world stage
and in the wakes of the Iraq and
Afghanistan war like this war weariness
here at home this sense that you know we
tried it failed let's go home the idea
that America's done more bad than good
on the world stage well what happens
when we pull back from the world we're
seeing it and the war in Iraq was a
crime it was a mistake and it was a
crime in my opinion that does not mean
that America has no role in the world
and you know all Putin the leaders of
China of Iran they're all banging on
endlessly about this beautiful new
multi-polar world and there are idiots
in the west who are like oh yeah
multipolar world no the multi-polar
world is just a new axis of Evil yes
that's what it is right and and the
process of breaking down the world we
currently have
looks like this it looks like Armenia
and aeran Ukraine and Russia Israel and
Palestine and God knows what else God
knows what and God forbid China and
Taiwan yeah yeah and this is this is the
multi-polar world all these people
wanted and the PX Americana I have to
say was a very good was a very good
situation your use of the past tense is
a very troubling thing to me yeah but
look at the world oh 100% And but this
idea that America is evil and is the
evil empire that's starts at the
universities yes it does I I mean I
can't count the number of seminar this
is going back years now the number of
classes I took at Colombia where the
idea of decolonization was put forward I
mean I was marinating in all of these
ideas now I had enough of a sense of
right and wrong and a sense of who I was
in the world that when I I'll give you
one example I remember very clearly
getting into a conversation with a
friend who also identified as a feminist
and she was justifying female genital
mutilation to me because she believed
that we in the west didn't have the
right to judge other people and cultures
that it was chauvinistic for us to do so
that it was sort of the mark of
colonization for us to do so and I
remember so clearly I was like a
sophomore in college stepping back from
that conversation and saying whatever
this is I'm not that whatever ideology
this is that could justify the
mutilation of women under the guise of I
don't know what
righteousness is is wrong and that I
remember so clearly that day it sort of
sent me sent me tumbling down this path
to really ex examine this ideology that
I was encountering in so many different
facets in so many different courses and
and basically what was coming back to me
again and again was just this idea that
anything the West Was was wrong to put
it crudely any values that claim to be
Western were in and of themselves
chauvinistic and and oppressive toward
other people and I had to step back and
say but hold on these values have
literally allowed for my life to be
possible these values have literally
allowed for the greatest flourishing of
equality of human dignity of Rights for
minorities that we have ever seen in the
history of the world so those people who
are claiming that we should just go and
dismantle them we should look at those
people with an enormous amount of
skepticism and right now we're seeing
the fruits of their ideology and they
are very very terrible ones as a
Venezuelan I really do appreciate it
when a Colombian gr Colombia graduate
explains to me that socialism is a
beautiful thing it's it's it's wonderful
but it you know I'm being you know glib
about it but there's a very serious
point to be made there in that and I say
to these people when be Rose to power
and you know people were championing it
particularly in our industry and comedy
and I said the words to them you do not
know the forces that you were messing
with you have no idea you have never
seen I have believe me it's not pretty
but you you can't explain that to people
who've never seen it well there was an
incredible I'm sure you guys saw that
BLM Chicago put out an image yeah I
think the words where we stand with
Palestine of the image of death the
image of a Hamas paraglider and I think
a lot of sort of good progressives
imagine that it was somehow a mistake
and then and then days later BLM Chicago
put out a tweet that was so true they
said if you're shocked by that image you
haven't been paying attention to what we
believe and they're right they're right
people didn't want to pay attention CU
they didn't want to see because they
wanted to be with the cool kids they
wanted to be on the side of the good
they wanted to go along with something
that pretended to be
anti-racism but was actually about
something far more Insidious and it's
and it's you see it with the college
kids with the pictures of sh and you
know and exactly and I remember when I
was at University and I said to him do
you know who she is do you have any
knowledge of him do you know for
instance that he was a rank homophobe
who despised gay people and had them
executed do you know that but this is
like when I'm seeing people with signs
that are like queers for Palestine you
know I'm like I I saw this unbelievable
instin of this trans person at a rally
you know cheering on what had happened I
wanted to say do you know what they
would do to you do you know what they
would do to you there it's I mean the
the
oxymoron of of queers for Palestine it's
just it's unbelievable yeah stay away
from tall buildings oh my gosh actually
they qu Pro turns in in Iran in Iran
they are yeah yes um well for the
reasons of they don't want there to be
gay people yes
um it's a very interesting moment right
now in terms of what's happening in the
west and I wonder if this is you know
look I think what one thing we should
also acknowledge is I see people posting
this thing as like you know when they
came for these people I stood up when
they came for these people I stood up
and then when they came for the Jews no
one stood up cuz and I don't think
that's true I think we've seen a
tremendous outpouring of support I mean
that speech by Eric Adams the mayor of
New York unbelievable unbelievable
unbelievable and I'm also hearten
Douglas Murray's speech yeah did you see
that in the synagogue yes oh my God yeah
I think amazing we also ought to
acknowledge that um the world was
shocked by what happened and many many
people stood up and said something and I
hope that this is a wakeup call for
people in the west I'll be honest with
you we've been in in the you think it
will be well this is what I was going to
say I'll be honest with you what I saw I
wasn't in London I have many people
friendss in London Jewish friends and
non-jewish friends who I've been
speaking to about what I saw
there this may sound like hyperbole but
I don't see how this issue gets better
in the UK we have an open border we
don't vet the people who are coming in
um this is only going to get worse in
the UK but in America it feels like to
me there's there's a fight to be had
over the future of this country and the
attitude it takes to all of issues so
what does I'm just what does that mean
for the future of the UK If you believe
nothing good nothing good I I mean I I
don't see how it gets better do you feel
that way too Francis I think there's
always hope I think there's always hope
you've got to have hope and you've got
to believe things can change and
that there there are always bad moments
and there are always dark moments and
there will always be dark moments in
history and there will always be dark
moments in life but that doesn't mean
that the darkness will continue and that
I hope that people people who have that
people are starting to wake up that
people who are actually going you know
what this ideology isn't good this they
may because they're very intelligent
they say they say nice things and they
promise Simple Solutions to complex
problems but actually this is a maskoff
moment and you're really seeing what's
going on but this isn't what I'm talking
about at all the fact that people are
going to realize werness is dumb great
okay cool but that isn't the issue we
have in the UK the issue we have in the
UK is we have a significant minority of
people who openly support what Hamas did
and we are importing more of those
people every day the 50,000 people that
I saw marching how many of those people
are immigrants and how many aren't I
have no idea nobody does I we know none
of us know what percentage of those
people actually support Hamas and what
percentage of those people just think
Palestinians are being badly treated we
don't know but uh we what we do know is
there are some among them who support
wamas did and the police refused to do
anything about it the police Hamas is a
prescribed terrorist organization in the
UK which means that if you express
public support for hamash you should be
arrested and in my opinion deported
right that's not going to happen MH uh
the last time there was a flare up so to
speak in the Middle East we had people
uh who drove down for hours from a
different City to London to Jewish areas
of London with Palestine flags and
screamed using megaphones [__] Jewish
women rape Jewish women kill Jews those
people were not prosecuted for what they
did even though it is the law of the
land that they why were they not
prosecuted not enough evidence it was on
tape I saw on camera yeah yeah so uh the
mayor of New York stands up and gives a
speech saying I am your brother I stand
with Israel the mayor of London stands
up and says diversity is our
strength so I think another big change
that's happening in the American Jewish
Community this this week is I mean I I
think people will know this but seven
out of 10 Jews vote Democrat we always
have you know American Jews are
overwhelmingly liberal why Barry I don't
get it why why why because because
historically Republican the Republican
party was a xenophobic party did not
welcome immigrants did not have a social
safety net and had deep anti-Semitism at
its roots that's why history okay now
I'm not explaining that I I wonder
actually how this week may have changed
things but I but I definitely think that
American
Jews see how vulnerable we are see how
vulnerable Jewish communities are around
the world and
are definitely like the number of people
on my WhatsApp and signal and text
saying we should learn how to use a gun
people who I never in a million years
would think about owning a gun are are
now changing their minds real fast and
also as well you know there were a lot
of Metropolitan liberal Jews in London
in New York and all of these places well
I put it to you that's about to change I
mean one of the things we've only got a
couple of minutes you're very busy
is I think we are going to see
uh the overturn window but also politics
shift to the right now I think it's
inevitable that's already been happening
yeah but yes I agree with that yeah I
agree the question is you know will that
look like how rightwing will it go yeah
right and yeah that's a worry that's a
huge worry I mean there there are a lot
of don't forget like Bill Maher had a
great top to his show this past week
where he said you know the far left and
the far right have United on one thing
and it's hating the Jews and there have
been a lot of statements put out by
influential people on the sort of
so-called new right in this country
justifying or explaining away the
slaughter too or are basically ex or
basically not caring about it too much
because because they view it as the new
current thing same people that put their
pronouns in their bio and then the
Ukraine flag well now we got to support
Israel and we don't want America we we
want to you know look out for America we
don't want America involved in world
affairs and that that sort of Brew of
sort of Neo isolationism combined with
sort of latent anti-Semitism combined
with the revulsion at you know whatever
the you know current thing ism is have
led them to be sort of silent in the
face of a massacre that is also very
alarming agreed Barry we got to let you
go before we do uh we always end with
the same question as you know which is
what's the one thing we're not talking
about that we should be oh God I know
there's one thing on the front at the
front of your mind of course but this
probably brings to light other things
that you might want to bring to our
audience attention one thing I've been
thinking about this week is the number
of women I know in this country who
after Trump got elected put on their
[__] hats and marched for for women's
rights terrified that Trump was going to
sort of ort of bring in a real bring the
handmaid's tale to reality or who were
taking to the streets and certainly the
oped pages of our
newspapers in favor of me too and the
idea of believe all women well here we
are where rape has been used as a weapon
of war against Israeli women some of
whom have been taken hostages and I
don't think I've seen a single statement
from a feminist organization in this
country about it what does that tell you
about the actual state of American
feminism what happened to the idea of
believing women well I guess not in the
case of them being Jewish
women there is a very simple chord of
this right the concept of jihad the
concept of martyrdom the the very clear
totaling death cult I get yeah death to
apostates right all the this is this is
the clearest piece of code this is like
you know eight lines of code that every
time you run them prod the fact it's the
clearest piece of codame it's the fact
that it has no repressor bound to it to
borrow a metaphor from DNA
[Music]
so